peu
[Musique]
écoutez les bonnes gens la cruelle
douloureuse histoire
il fut l'incarnation du mal et que ceux
ci sert d'exemple à tous ceux que le
diable égard le droit chemin
petit à l'école à la place de crayon et
la benelli
en guise de cravates des cordes de l'ain
ne vous étonnez pas
là c'est surtout premiers cris puis
d'avoir fait mourir leur maman de
chagrin
ce télé d'assaut
les personnes
les salles est parfait
il s'était débrouillé pour rattraper la
rage est ficelé le docteur qui faisait
les vaccins
et les contes animés
or les gens du voisinage
amusante aller mordre lui accusé les
chiens avec avatar
c'étaient les dalton
tagada tagada y avait personne
et de valeur des hommes
[Musique]
un conseil mon ami avant de les croiser
embrasse à ta femme serment la main
vite sur la vie
il va te perds assuré
quand je dois la gorge est de 3,6
c'étaient les datas
tagada tagada n'y a plus personne
la justice payer
comme tous les journaux de thomas belmas
en pis pressenti à l'erika qui s'était
vanité avides d'argent et se livraient
remets
pour toucher la prairie carry trade est
encore plus bête que méchant
l'état
tagada tagada des personnes
[Musique]
lui